I want to do all my ratings off movies
based off a kind of drug like oh if you
go on shrooms to watch Warcraft it's
gonna be okay time it's gonna be trippy
you're gonna feel like you're really
there if you go to watch like a Judd
Apatow movie go on weed you know if
you're gonna watch like another crank
film take some cocaine yeah but this
isn't necessarily a rating anymore it's
like pairing wines except instead of
wine it's an entrees it's drugs and
movies why people yeah that's right
hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Ryan
right I'm Jerry so anyway guys today
we're gonna check out the trailer the
official trailer number one for Warcraft
that's right world of world up no no
it's just called Warcraft it's just go
Warcraft yeah yeah they thought
marketing purposes it wouldn't be smart
to the world of in I guess it's more
bold of a title people are just gonna
call it Warcraft anyway disclaimer front
we are the most qualified people we are
we are hardcore gaming fans most
important I'm is play Warcraft we're of
course kidding we don't know anything
about it never buy your crap we're gonna
judge this trailer based off the trailer
alone from a cinematic point of view
let's do the Roy Jenkins
that's a Warcraft thing I think
Universal no monetization today woo
blizzard
for years our world has been at peace
that something is coupled because I can
feel the dark forces are Parnell's
what's gorgeous find these beasts or
whatever they are
our world is dying there is nothing to
go back to if our people are to survive
we must make our media never happens if
we do not unite our world will perish it
doesn't happen there's one who may help
us no but what does humans help
there could be money to save all people
humans
and we trusted
and that beasts they should all be
destroyed are you sure about that
[Music]
we will protect the kingdom you and I
I'm sorry the tubers look it's too kind
this is suicide no see we have their
choice vision attack at full force
everything to do do it now
[Music]
[Music]
interesting this isn't a knock
necessarily but I feel like that movies
gonna give me a headache that it's got
that that sort of harsh look a lot of
the battle stuff and I imagine it would
be very loud what I like about what I'm
getting from this was I was worried I
was gonna be like this looks like a
ripoff of a lot of movies I feel like
it's honoring the genre but it's not a
ripoff it is kind of cuz I mean it you
know it it's fantasies reminiscent stuff
of like Lord of the Rings and there yet
worse you know it's creatures in fantasy
and you know World of Warcraft I'm sure
borrowed from Lord of the Rings anyway
the few things I know about Warcraft
looked like they made it into this movie
so that's that bodes well for them you
know it seems like they bothered to at
least I don't put a lot of the look in
the I like the plot of the orcs having
to work with the humans because you know
especially in fantasy movies orcs are
portrayed as villainous and they're not
exactly humans number one companions so
the idea of them working together that
could be that could make for a cool film
however there were aspects of it were
with the orcs especially with the family
stuff and little baby Shrek that doesn't
look real at all this is obviously a
very expensive movie and I kind of wish
they would have done the Edward the
troll thing which mean in Hansel and
Gretel witch hunters the troll guy was
was like an actual practical puppet yeah
a suit that the actor could wear it it
looked really good and it looked real
emigrants and having a lot of those is
probably really hard all the orc guys
I'm like this is really good CG but it's
really good CG yeah look the only
Estelle CG like it's almost there it
doesn't look quite real it just looks
pretty good you know now because at the
end of the day it's like it's a computer
animation being put into real world so
you can definitely pick up on the CG and
I don't know if that would be a drawback
or not just cuz a lot of the colors and
a lot of the stuff going on it does look
like a video game I guess if you
maintain a certain levels of not quite
photo realism you can sort of use that
to your advantage cuz it'll look like a
fantasy game and I don't know much about
World of Warcraft but I do know a lot
about video game trailers video games
are being adopted into film that was one
of the better ones I've ever seen I
never
know how to feel about these it's like
you know Dungeons & Dragons didn't go so
well
that looks like crap yeah I did it I
don't know you know this could be really
cool or it could not be really cool and
I feel like we won't know until it's out
but a lot of people are gonna go there
with especially for non World of
Warcraft fans or the battle sequences
yeah and the battle sequences do look
fantastic I feel like whatever the lack
and substance they might make up for in
effects and action sequences hey I make
for a great summer movie it's a June
yeah and a 16 movie you know you know I
don't think you're gonna go to this
looking for you know vast amounts of
substance however this is the video game
community and a big complaint for video
game adaptations is they can a lot of
story but World of Warcraft is like it
is like an MMORPG like it's just an open
like you create your own story and
everyone's is different you know you you
choose what kind of creature you want to
be I don't know if Warcraft uses the
same like character content spectrum as
Dungeons and Dragons you know there's
like different levels of good or evil or
neutral you know characters and stuff I
don't know if there's an exact storyline
I think you just kind of make it
yourself I would have chosen to be a
dwarf what did yeah that way when I eat
out a woman I could just stand I
wouldn't date another dwarf I would date
a regular-sized human knows Arabs and
Warcraft I'd have to check well I would
make sure to include it in some way get
some DLC character in there yeah there
you go
then the vague things I know it looks
like it holds true to the spirit of
Warcraft it's just whatever story they
chose to put it in what I want though
what I really am hoping for is that
there's a sense of fun that's what
turned me off a little bit was yeah like
super super self-important yeah you're
not Lord of the Rings and that's kind of
the point that's what I feared because
I'm like I you could be a lot more
forgiving with other things if it's not
so heavily bent on being such a self
serious film yeah I'm not ignoring you I
want to make sure before I name check
this guy this is Duncan Joseph's movie I
hope David Bowie shows up as the guy
from labyrinth because that would be
really cool did you go through all my
meb just to make that one drip no I was
making sure cuz I didn't want to talk
about Duncan Jones it's like Duncan
Jones is a really good director if
people really like moon and an even
source code I'm curious about
how he's gonna handle this gigantic
movie when you get directors who are not
given like who not don't usually do
films on such a large scale yeah and
they're known for such creative
direction they tend to get you know
cornered by Studios and they're like
more conventional you know yeah yeah and
so that's what I'm curious about here is
because I used to be excited like god
they got a cool director Jews movie now
I'm sort of like I don't know yeah he's
just gonna be the babysitter exactly
yeah in terms of like effects visual
imagery it looks like it's all there in
terms of like unique story not really I
feel like when I go to the theater in
June I'm gonna be like I'm gonna move
for a really entertaining spectacle I'm
not really here for I would like a good
story I mean it's always a treat it's
always a treat when there's a lot of
substance yeah but if it's not there I'm
not gonna be like surprised that's not
there or letdown that it's not there
yeah I hope it doesn't take itself too
too seriously I kind of feel from where
I'm sitting right now I sort of feel
like I'll see this if I end up seeing
this movie I'll probably have fun and I
probably won't stick with me it doesn't
look like the kind of movie that will
stick with you necessarily cuz it's a
lot of stuff we've seen so many times
now just with warcraft wallpaper but who
knows maybe it'll be super you mean it
might be a good time with no alcohol
required or awesome tacular who might be
awesome tacular who knows hopefully it's
not dog hopefully it's at least worth
buying on blu-ray at least worth buying
on blu-ray anyway guys that's it for
today if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button become a reject or reject or get
checked orc
yeah and you get I check out reasons to
Jerry Jerry's movie reviews and dank ass
dubs a podcast hosted by said Jerry on
this channel
Preston Leedy whoo he said something
hello I'm a big fan of yours Preston you
look dude you gotta say something
interesting in order to earn a shout-out
now I'm just gonna make fun of you
congratulations even if you say
something interesting I would have made
funny when I'm with he's clearly
watching a Sakura gangbang by black
people video I don't think you were able
to glean that information from just this
this well you can see the reflection off
his glasses yeah but it's hard to tell
what it is in the suit blue murder no no
I can see it pretty well there's there's
like two black penises right there in
his eyes there's asa there's a [ __ ] shot
you're too young to be watching this
stuff yeah I'm kidding I started when I
was young too and I ended up fine